[Music] playing
with the core
ladies and gentlemen good morning and
welcome to the netherlands to amsterdam
home to one of the world's biggest
internet exchanges and the light it to
be speaking to the people who image
the infra structure that will enable
european suite feel ben  it benefit
of the digital age
the netherlands mtb leader in this field
and who lift and replication to uphold
who where the first country and europe to
gain access to the internet in my 10th
diet because i was silent the crisis on the
military and the academic  community
in which nineteen to the free it was
opened up to everyone around the world
oil was occasionally slow the wwii the you
could easily have done for world wide
ranging
the aim is to ensure that where ever you
marine netherlands
dual have the perfect could activity  that is
the collective 10 june
when work in the cloud de stream tv
programs in 3d or to gold en video put
several people at once
prima see is the opportunities over few
dig  ital
wit offered him the digital transformation
is crucial for strong dutch economy is
already leading to ground breaking
solutions to issues facing society ex
apples inclusion itself
video conference to use the not for
visico mobility and the use of thrones
for precision farming
and after the  key component of my police is
preventing and digital the fight met de
kelly already spoke about it every man
must be given the chance to benefit from
high speed internet where de db jammer
old and live in it to old country and
specially in the let's case
brother of light is resulting in
population imbalances
qua we do this top collective team
will help ensure
rural areas stay effects for families
and economy
activity how do you live keep track of keep track of
target of one hundred megabits
per second
is progressing for everyone in the
netherlands' that's  why i have the paint is
so big red with the map shows the
speed on the fixed internet connection at
various levels from count  ry to
adress level
recently in the east of the country and
visually lunch de dutch 3 million
fiber connection medicare van
this meter internet hundred times faster
allowing them to digitize
erin tire operation en je netflix
van de sofa
off course our je let it in it
dutch again in a privileged
precision
ik us from the bigger country life french becomes
striking who needs the dutch
pink and rural oil through my big
smile to your face
what a dress is to ensure that
promote adresjes in your country
get high speed connection to  leds white
pink who doesn't to modify the rules us t
know how you can do this home old
fibernet prefer to be in the netherlands
there can be places where fiber networks
on not from national fire tree this is
were
government should be able to rent rent
and all  respect the government should
look out look out is regulation
if you want to lay fiber game of than in
the netherlands and many other countries
jungshef' de side en  the how it widely
varying municipal and provincial
regulations for example how deep do you know
this work and your president and aore
testing station
what is the per with do you produce and become
if it costs
hear old rules and restoring the red
service once the work is complete
and  warm where that you left to go to
great lengths to buy the Houthi's teams
in each and ever ever i locality
where you drive so in the Dutch to
promoting the share of best practices
so these local authorities know that with
so that has brute and success  elsewhere
and there is quatuor uniformity
ladies and gentlemen mr kelly and 6 sets
and play store it is an absolute speak
for rent you chose business and government
not each other in order to offer people
in a concrete
the best possible digital collective that
from touched on a  couple of areas where
i've feel the government can modify its
approach
it is mainly about helping to connect
dream homes and promoting and fish and
regulation  the duty of
government
working within the elephant full and
administrative karteria not to make
jotas'
en infrastructure companies more
difficult than it already is so
let's work together let's create half
the market for business business and the
digital society that works for at all
thank you very  much for your attention
[Applause]